welcome to the the Hegel webinar this
time we're going to be talking about
probably the most famous idea that Hegel
has a a little bit undeservedly because
there's a lot of other great stuff in
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit but
that's what we're going to be focusing
on before we begin we're going to get
familiar with it the technology for
those who haven't been in on this I'll
do some introductions and some opening
questions and then we'll jump right into
some lecture about the text and we'll do
some discussion later what I want to do
is situate this section first in the
greater work of the phenomenology and
then talk about the things that lead up
to the master-slave dialectic and then
talk about the actual master-slave
dialectic itself and we'll have about 20
minutes of time at the end for open
discussion and Q&A using the technology
if you're not if you're not talking you
want to need the microphone because we
are recording this you want to use
headphones when your mic is on otherwise
you're going to get a lot of feedback
and then you can ask questions or make
comments in two different ways you can
use the microphone or use the chat
interface I'll be checking both of those
since AMD isn't here and I'll read any
questions that people have in the chat
interface out loud but like I said we'll
take questions at the end so let's do
some introductions the person that we're
focusing on is this guy you know we
usually just say GW GWF Hegel right
Georg Wilhelm Friedrich Hegel it's quite
a mouthful and he is a really you know
first-rate philosopher but he's also
very difficult he's a key figure in this
tradition that we call German idealism
and his early work that that tends to
draw the most notice in our century and
also the century before is the
phenomenology of spirit I would say that
in his own time it was less to fit
nology and more his two logics and the
philosophy of right that drew a lot of
attention
I'm Greg Sadler I'm the president and
co-founder of reason i/o I'm also as
probably most of you know the producer
of the half-hour Hegel commentary series
which is a set of videos going through
Hegel's phenomenology one paragraph or
two paragraphs at a time in half an hour
chunks or now about three and a half
years into the project and we have got
about another two years to go to finish
it out so let's talk first about how we
situate this master-slave dialectic
within the text of the phenomenology
itself where does the master-slave
dialectic fit into this larger text now
I think a lot of people perhaps you know
when they when they first hear about it
they don't realize that it's actually
just a small part of a fairly short
portion of a giant work so the
master-slave dialectic is part of the
self consciousness section and the self
consciousness section is actually one of
the shortest pieces within the work it
is a very important treatment of how
human self consciousness develops and it
does set the stage for what follows but
it's not Hegel's last word on human
relations or even on how labor works or
social dynamics or anything like that
and it's incomplete in how it winds up
like I put here it provides one
incomplete culmination for a much larger
problem in in Hegel's text and that is
what we call the problematic of
self-consciousness and recognition so
that that's kind of a lot of jargon
there we'll go into that and talk about
what that means and it's followed by a
much longer section of
self-consciousness which we can talk
about in the Q&A if you want that part
is called stoicism skepticism and the
unhappy consciousness and it outlines
three you might say basic attitudes
that arise within ancient culture for
how you you know how self-consciousness
develops beyond the master-slave
dialectic so right there that should
show us that the master-slave dialectic
is not the final word
if you look at this slide I've taken the
structure of the phenomenology and kind
of zeroed in on the master-slave
dialectic so you notice that we begin
with the preface and introduction the
preface is actually pretty long it's
about one eleventh the length of the
works that's that's a very long preface
and then we have this consciousness
section and there's a lot going on in
there one of the most difficult portions
of the work force on the understanding
is found at the end of the consciousness
section then we have self-consciousness
and that's a fairly short section you
notice master/slave is situated right in
the middle of that sandwiched between
the truth itself certainty the
introductory stuff and stoicism
skepticism and the unhappy consciousness
and then we have these other sections
reason spirit religion absolute knowing
on those the only one that's actually
fairly short is the absolute knowing
which is the the end section that's our
the make-or-break point of the work if
you've been following with Hegel all
along up to that point you might still
say I don't I don't completely buy it
the religion section is pretty long
spirit and reason each of those is over
200 paragraphs so each of them is a
giant portion of the work right now in
the half hour Hegel project we're
actually at the early parts of the
spirit section so you can you can see
you know where the master-slave
dialectic fits in it's very early on in
the work and it's you know part of this
this self-consciousness portion so let's
take a look at what's going on in that
that section before we actually get to
the master-slave dialectic so here he's
talking about life desire the nature of
self-consciousness and we're looking at
paragraphs 166 to 177
so here's some questions that we can
start with when we think about self
consciousness we're already being self
conscious and you know it can lead to a
kind of vertigo we start realizing that
we're thinking about thinking makes
things rather complicated for us but
this is also something that we're able
to do all the time as human beings you
know every time that you think to
yourself I am late what do what are
people going to think of me you are
engaged in self-consciousness and in a
rather explicit way so the question that
we want to think about is what does it
mean to being self-conscious as opposed
to being merely conscious what is it to
be conscious of yourself as opposed to
being conscious of an object and we also
want to try to retain you know what I've
put here as the movement the fluidity
the reflexivity of self-consciousness
that's important in any account we don't
want to try to reduce self-consciousness
to another kind of object or to say a
set of algorithms as we might you know
think about today where everybody is
particularly interested in modeling
things and the question that Hegel is
going to be concerned with is whether
self-consciousness can be something
entirely self-contained identical to
itself secure in itself something that
can can be independent on its own and a
few key ideas that that are going to
come up that I think you may have
encountered another places so so Hegel
has a contrast that runs throughout the
entire phenomenology and sometimes it
means a little bit different things in
other places between being in himself or
being for another and then being for
self and you might say that's very
abstract what does that mean well it
here would be a concrete example being
in itself is the kind of the kind of
being that objects have for us which
means they're being for another they're
being for our consciousness when I think
about my
phone you know even if I like talk to
Siri or something like that I don't
really think serious a person I think
series a nice sort of algorithms I'm
treating that as something that really
just says being for me now if I find
myself I suppose getting into some sort
of projected relationship with Siri and
worrying about what she thinks
Corky thinks or whatever then I'm
projecting something like being for self
on to that artificial intelligence most
of the time that we're doing this we're
thinking about our own self and we're
what we make of ourselves and and Hegel
says something really cool here in
paragraph 167 he says with
self-consciousness we have entered the
native realm of truth and this brings up
another key idea in the Hegelian
dialectic as you see it working its way
through there's this constant back and
forth where Hegel will begin from a
starting point of certainty or let's
call it apparent certainty something
that we can take for granted and we
think we can we can work our way outward
from there and so we do and we you know
try to think our environment or our
relations with others what it is that
we're doing from this basis of certainty
and in the process we start to encounter
what you might call the demands of
something else which is truth we want to
have a coherent view on things and as
we're doing the work of developing that
coherent view the certainty starts to
vanish we become less sure of ourselves
where we're now able to develop further
and develop our accounts further but we
lose that certainty when we obtain the
truth and we want to find a way to bring
those two together and you see this
playing itself out existentially in
human lives you know for example when a
person is digging into their past and
the things that they thought they were
absolutely certain about fall away but
they attain a kind of truth that
requires them to to grow or at least to
perhaps grow around like
an oyster around a girl you know now the
other key idea that is running
throughout this is Hegel talks about
self consciousness being desire in
general and the German word for that is
big eared which can also mean hunger and
this means that self-consciousness is
not just you know consciousness in the
sense of representation or modeling or
you know replicating what-what it's an
encountering or even doing so in a
reflexive way it's also shot through
with desire with effectivity with an
orientation towards things there's
there's going to be some agency involved
so when Hegel talks about life early on
in this section
he says that you know life in general
differentiates itself into a plenitude
of living things all sorts of different
living things and the question is how do
we how do we bring that movement back
together self consciousness is a
particular kind of life in this section
for Hegel and he says that it exists
through superseding its other you notice
there's that term Alf Haven which is
difficult to translate sublation is how
it gets translated in a lot of cases and
you might think of superseding here as
not just nullifying but rather as
integrating as taking in what's
essential in in what is being superseded
and retaining it and making it part of a
larger framework and the question is how
do you do that with another how do you
do that with another person this is
where the master-slave dialectic is
going to be showing us one way that that
can happen there's also a problematic
involved in other 'no sit self and that
gets explored in paragraphs 175 and 176
you know what if we had to sort of put
it in a you know bullet point form it's
that self-consciousness it can only
really attain its satisfaction what it
is that it's looking for in another self
conscious
us not just in itself in a you know you
know totally isolated or even in our
sophisticated the other as other but
that always places it add a kind of risk
self-consciousness is also looking for
something that will be you might say a
stable set of relations its seeking what
Hegel calls recognition and his word for
recognition is on air cannon it means to
to know when we talk about really
knowing somebody else and we don't just
mean knowing things about them but
actually knowing who they are and you
know for good or bad and seeing you know
the kind of person that they are and
acknowledging it that's what he's
talking about there
and that's uh that's something that
Hegel thinks that all self-consciousness
is really are desiring they don't always
attain it
oftentimes they may not be developed
enough or society may not be developed
in such a way as to allow them to have
that recognition but it's something
that's that's fundamentally motivating
us so this brings us to the struggle for
recognition and now we we get into the
master-slave dialectic you know proper
but this is really the lead up to it i
mean he's a paragraph 178 and onward
he's talking about this is all part of
the lordship and bondage or master and
slave section but we don't yet have a
master enslave again we should think
about a few starting questions that that
can help us you know if we look at our
own present era what are what are we
doing when we try to attain recognition
is it something like what's hate what
Hegel is describing here or is it
something that's a bit more complex or
advanced another thing to think about is
what happens when a person gets forced
into a position where they're not
recognized which is the case often times
there's many of us who are forced into
being bit players at best or whose say
labor is exploited
or who wind up you know being repressed
or ignored and then you know the other
question why is it so important that
there's an other involved why can't why
can't you just say at this time provide
recognition for yourself perhaps through
the intermediary of technology or or
some other similar thing now Hagel
himself is something I wanted to call
your attention to this is a little bit
of a digression but I think people may
they find it interesting Hagel is going
to talk about the relation to the other
in terms of this doubling and he uses a
lot of plays on words
so there's faired Oakland which is a
doubling or duplication he talks in
terms of something being ambiguous Delta
he also talks in terms of what what you
know German word for ambiguity Delta's
in is is and you know if you look at the
Greek root ambiguity has the same sort
of sense it's coming from humble which
means both and so an ambiguity is where
something can be looked at in in two or
more ways self consciousness itself is
doubled and ambiguous he tells us it's
doubled within itself so it doesn't have
a completely stable identity that it can
rely upon or which it could represent to
itself and that actually be the true
thing he also talks about it being
doubled in its own meaning and then it
gets even more complicated it's doubled
in another self-consciousness namely the
other and and think about it this way
everything that's going on on the one
side of self-consciousness is going on
on the other side of the other
self-consciousness
and so there's something you might think
of as almost like a feedback loop
happening that that's that's that's
involved with this so all that that
stuff said
we can come back to the actual
development what's actually happening
here according to Hegel
so both self-consciousness are going
through this this process of doubling
and sort of losing what it is that that
constituted there at least what they
felt like to be a stable identity
there's a really nice sum up like I put
here in the short paragraph 183 so I'm
just going to read this
thus the action has a double
significance not only because it is
directed against itself as well as
against the other but also because it is
indivisibly the action of one as well as
of the other so the action that's
involved here which is a kind of primal
action on the part of both self
consciousnesses is not only directed
against the other person but also you
know you might say we're downs to
oneself and it's the same action that
both of them are engaging each
self-consciousness winds up being made
what Hegel calls and he really loves to
talk in these terms throughout the
entire phenomenology the middle term the
thing that is unifying them so then that
takes that that's actually worth pausing
out a minute what what does he mean by
saying it's the middle term didn't we
have each self-consciousness on the
opposite side from each other yes and
and so to say that each of them is the
middle term means that each of them is
mediating between themselves
and the other and as being mediated by
the other in that way as well you could
say that we can only really be ourselves
when we're in some sort of productive
relationship with the other and here's
where it comes to the crux each of these
self consciousnesses wants to be
securely recognized it wants to have its
certainty but it doesn't yet have what
Hegel calls truth so how is this going
to show up each of them has to show its
independence in relation to life so
here's where I think some people might
say I don't understand why it has to go
this way Hegel you know couldn't they
maybe work something out
between them like a nice contract or
something like that Hegel doesn't
consider that he says each of them seeks
the death of the other and they do so by
risking their own life so there's still
this you know reciprocity going on and
there's an interrelationship between
genuine human freedom and this risk of
putting one's life on the line now if
they happen to kill each other or if one
of them kills the other then all bets
are off and there is no dialectical
advance however if one of them does
something different this is where we get
to the dialectic of Master and slave now
we have in advance so here Hegel talks
about there being a vital difference
between the two self consciousness is
vital in a couple different senses that
we can explore later if you want to one
of them displays a full indifference and
thereby enacts its own freedom towards
death the other one wants to live more
than it then it you know it wants to be
independent and it gives it out of fear
for its own existence so what do we have
here this is a primal moment for Hegel
where one of the consciousnesses becomes
independent it's essential nature is to
be for itself and he becomes the Lord or
master the other one becomes dependent
and it's given its life but it is for
another it becomes you know the older
translation is the bondsman or you know
now the more modern translation slave so
the master is able to engage in enjoying
the world and consuming the world
through the slave and he does this in in
two ways
he gets recognition from the slave so
the slave is telling the master whatever
it is master wants to know about himself
perhaps not necessarily through words
but sometimes just through you know what
they where what they have to do you know
what the master can impose upon the
slave and at the same time the slave is
is
working on things and giving those to
the master who then enjoys it and so you
know the master is is at first at least
fundamentally motivated by something
going beyond the kinds of goods that we
usually attribute to people who like to
be in charge it's not just power it's
not just pleasure it's not just greed
for Hegel recognition is at the very
center of things but the recognition
that the master can can get is going to
slip away and the slave is going to be
developing in ways that escape what's
going on with the master so we need to
look at that side so the slave is put to
work on things and we might think of all
sorts of examples you know let's say we
take somebody who has to create clothing
or who is stuck cooking the meals
cleaning up all those sorts of things
right the slave works with things that
are independent of them I mean everybody
who's worked a crappy job you know where
you're dealing with tools or dealing
with you know making food or cleaning
things off you know exactly what it's
like to have the world resist your
activities right and you're able to
impose some word around it perhaps but
it's never exactly what what you were
thinking so the slave is going through a
kind of apprenticeship not from the
master but from the things that they're
working with they're also having to
develop because of this deferment of
desire and this is where things get
really interesting so what is the slave
desire the slave
desire is the same kind of recognition
that the master is getting which the
slave is not going to get they also have
desires for other things you know more
common desires the slave would like to
sleep in the slave would like to eat
nice food the slave would like to enjoy
the sorts of things that everybody else
in that society does and the slate has
to put that off so that allows us to
slave to develop so the slave is
encountering and negating the
independence of the things that he works
on and his work forms and shapes things
individual things but eventually
an entire social world in which both
master and slave exists so the slave and
here's where you know this is
distinctively human the slave works upon
himself between the master and the
object and what's going on there the
slave is actually attaining a kind of
agency a conditioned agency to be sure
because you know he probably wouldn't be
doing this stuff for the master wasn't
saying you need to do this or all I'll
injure you or hurt you so here's another
key element
what Hegel calls the fear of the Lord he
talks about an initial fear of death
that shakes the very being of the slave
and Hegel thinks that this is absolutely
essential
he says everything solid and stable has
been shaken to its foundations there's
kind of a pure negativity or we might
think of it as a pure plasticity of the
human being and by itself this
negativity of fear doesn't really
accomplish anything it just it just
scares the hell out of them and and
makes it malleable what has to make this
a something where development can take
place is the internalization of the
master the internalization of the lash
it's been put you know the punishment so
there's there's three things that are
necessary for the development of this
independent being fear a fear that
shakes him to the very core being put to
work in terms of service the
relationship to the master serving that
that person or that class or how we want
to think about it and then work as
formative activity and Hegel says that
if we don't have these the slave still
remains determinate being in the form of
self wheeler obstinacy as he sometimes
translates with as well so without that
there's no dialectical development with
those things
there is a dialectical development so
this is a lot I were a little bit past
the time that I was going to take up
this gives us plenty of time for Q&A so
about maybe 12:45 or if need be
even you know 1250 I'm going to unmute
everybody
I want extra question sure can hear me
okay ah the master later on the hell do
I have to consciousness
yeah they domestically citizen mouths
considered appeal category well in the
master-slave dialectic once use actually
established some sort of order and put
the slave to work the master really
doesn't do anything they just enjoy and
they don't develop in any important way
later on you're right in the unhappy
consciousness section we get a different
kind of master who is it turns out to be
the you know self-consciousness is sort
of you could say brick in this was the
wrong way to put it but breaks a lot a
portion of itself and projects it out
there into some beyond and then tries to
reach it and this is actually what
feuerbach you know discusses in his
works because he seems to fixate almost
exclusively on that part yeah but so
they're not the same master really oh
and even though the master in the
master-slave dialectic they're all
subject to another master which is staff
dealt absolute master yes yeah so the
the master who gets going back to the
master slave to have a dielectric the
master who gets to you know enjoy the
good life and and use slaves as
technology and make them work on things
he is just a dead end
dialectically yeah and we have lots and
lots of people like that I mean if we
want to try to apply this to the present
we might think of people who are just
involved in in consumption and enjoyment
yeah and you know they think themselves
like totally entitled to it yeah
they're they're not going to leave any
sort of mark on a move on the world or
history other than making people do
things the reason is because when I was
reading the and freedom of self
consciousness
it was saying that a
that is dialectical of mouth enslave now
it's on a single individual it's in the
individual as a the unhappy
consciousness so stoicism the frame like
II was saying stories of them about is
the pure consciousness be is true
because I think it's true so it will be
the pure conscious and I guess all
skeptical will be the other side you
know or is reaching out into existence
and the gain it would that be right
you're in part I mean with the
skepticism part it's it's not just
negating the you know the external world
and also the realization that one's own
position is a position that's being
staked out as an individual and thereby
that can be negated as well there's no
universality to it and so the skeptic is
placed in this kind of unhappy affective
condition which will lead to the unhappy
consciousness
Hey Dude I mean in a way Hegel he's
doing his typical kind of schematic
thing and we got this following this
following this right yeah he does say
that stoicism which is the first part of
that that section can only arise once
you actually have a society in which
sort of servitude has become universal
and yet because you know complex
societies in which everybody is is stuck
working for somebody and even the guy at
the top yeah happy time yeah so he's got
in mind like the Roman Empire's you know
yeah or you know the the Macedonian
successor States yeah going to have
something similar on with the only happy
consciousness yeah so you can say that
there is you know something let's call
it like an interjection of the master
there but then it's projected out as
this object of desire that you're you're
trying to reconnect with and and and
they're what Hagel has in mind are all
these
all these different religious let's call
them experiments and everybody you know
for how do you actually reach what is
most real what is divine
you know you try out philosophy first
and after that doesn't really work for
you then maybe let's try some Mithra ISM
or yeah health of Isis or what it
whatever you want yeah and he even has
like a little passage there on what you
know some church-going people call
smells and bells you know yeah you know
the you know using using all these
rituals and things like that mm-hmm
let me let me take this question that's
here in the chat from JUnit on has there
been any notable critique of this
dialectic from other philosophers yeah I
mean there's not only has there been
interesting critique of it there's been
a lot of interesting appropriation of it
so if we're thinking about critique you
know it would be that people are saying
okay Society doesn't really develop this
way or this this isn't really
fundamental or basic or Hegel is getting
something wrong I would say that that
one of the people who's implicitly
criticizing this over and over again is
Nietzsche because for Nietzsche in the
class of a masters they're not just
making the slaves do something and then
just like sitting around okay yeah
they're the ones who impose values and
it's the slave and the slaves
development that you know produces this
whole modern decadent culture of
resulted month so I would say Nietzsche
is probably one of the strongest critics
do you see other people incorporating it
into their ideas so Marx in his way is
is incorporating it you know you could
see what Freud is doing in civilization
and its discontents you know it's
talking about resolve the Freud stuff is
all kind of like you know what let's
imagine things were like this you know I
don't think that Freud really believed
that there was some sort of primal horde
or something like that any more than
Hegel
most societies began with a master-slave
dialectic that's exactly the way he
described but but it's a nice story and
so the function of repression and having
to work on things is kind of similar
there Sartre interestingly you know who
probably really like this the most as
John Paul Sartre yeah because he sees
human relations at least in Being and
Nothingness as almost completely doomed
to falling into something like the
master-slave dialectic or or something
similarly problematic for everybody
involved there's no possibility of
attaining any genuine recognition and
insert that that ever holds up and then
other people are critical of Sartre for
that reason I think it's important to to
remember that for Hegel this is just the
very beginning of the self-consciousness
section C and that feeds into reason and
spirit and there's much more complex
dialectics of recognition being worked
out in those so this is this isn't where
we go to find kegels full theory of
recognition if it was then it would be a
pretty dismal yeah result right I know I
would you know if you ask me well
master-slave dialectic pick one you're
going to be Anna master the slave I
don't know I suppose it's better to be
the slave in a way cause you're
developing but yeah
developing towards what there's there
has to be a something more they're not
happy consciousness well that's not yeah
that's that's that's no picnic either
yeah so woke up Nix after the massive
flame is done meta consciousness yeah
yeah I mean I think the real the real
key to this is you know it is it is
pointing out that we do develop through
having to be put to work on things I
think that's an important lesson to
learn from this and that it requires not
just our own decision oh I'm going to
you know master a language or something
like
that's what we're able to do and we're
like independent beings right yeah but
you know we we often develop precisely
because people make us they force us or
compel us into situations and they're
not themselves necessarily wanting us to
develop because you know we should
improve our being or something like that
they just want us to do X for them you
know so yeah boss may send you to
seminar emotional intelligence because
they want you to quit getting in
arguments with your coworkers right but
yeah that's still going to help you know
yeah if you take the seminar and subject
yourself to it you know yeah ha yeah any
other questions or lines of discussion
today and can you hear me I can't yeah
okay um first of all thanks to all the
friends to be bottled it because the
class really good I
you told professor Gregory that
recognition is a is a necessity right so
perhaps it could be our our our they
think that make is so beautiful nature
but at same time is our greatest problem
cuz in the search for recognition we we
get into this objective mode maybe and
we can we just can't get out from that
and to achieve this holistic view that
Hegel is trying to persuade us to that
is this is the only mode that really can
make us to achieve the truth right the
self cautions as a spear as it can be
why it's so hard for us to get out from
this desperation for recognition
and getting to this unstoppable
and trying to persuade others to see
ourselves as the essence right and and
not again what I mean right yeah and
that's what that's a really that's a
very fundamental question I think at the
basis of if there is an ethics in Hegel
recognition is at the center of it and
it gets worked out in different
different ways where we could say it's
like made available to us in different
ways and I suppose one of the one of the
issues is we don't just want recognition
we want it in the way that we want it
from the people when we want it you know
and we also there's a secondary problem
if we want to get it we also need to
give it to other people or else there
isn't going to be this kind of you know
free open exchange so if I if I can tell
you to recognize me like look here's a
great example you know the professor in
the classroom who needs to be the big
shot and and smarter than everybody else
and tell them how it is and they're
often terrible teachers right and you
know students see through that really
quickly
I said don't take this guy he's terrible
but though the people who are stuck in
his class they see that he's looking for
something from them but he's not willing
to give anything back except on his
terms
that can't ultimately work and so he go
he doesn't give us a complete answer for
what what a complete completely
reciprocal recognition would actually be
like but he's sketching out more and
more developed ways in which this we can
get closer to that and then I think we
in the present have to do the work to
think about what this would look like in
general and then what this would look
like in terms of specific
institutions you know so this is
actually getting kind of harmony but I
you know I would say it's good to think
about this in terms of particular fields
of our life so when you go into a store
to buy some products and you are engaged
in an economic transaction and you know
the store keeper because it's a small
business there's a lot of potential for
recognition to be taking part on both
sides does he give you a fair deal
do you treat him as if he's not you know
just there to to dispense things for you
you know these are possibilities on
teaching provides another different
example I would say that romantic
relationships also provide another very
important example or what happens within
families and generations you know as
children become older and have to be
actually treated as adults not just as
extensions of ourselves about which is
very difficult for many parents I think
you know so we can come up with lots and
lots of shields in which what you're
talking about
takes place but there's all these
possible pitfalls that have to do with
for Hagel the very structure of
consciousness like we don't want to go
back to something like a master-slave
dialectic we want to have something
where we can have stable relationships
with people that are not just based on
coercion right so it's not a full answer
to your question which is a very big
question but I'm sorry but it but it was
fairly good professor Gregory and I
think the first step would be we
recognize that we need to get
recognition and from that all we can be
more conscious in that trying to find
healthy ways to get this recognition
that's so vital and so central to our
Deen right yeah I think that makes that
makes very
good sense so I mean that that is
something people will often ask well
what do I do with eggle when I I read
him you know I mean I've got this this
big thick book and it's got all these
different you know dialectical
progressions and they're hard as hell to
understand but let's say now I've
understood them and I see this whole
development of consciousness during
history what do I do with that
you know again and and I think some of
the answer to that would be well you
take you take some of the individual
lessons and you you interject them into
your own concrete existence so realizing
that we do have that fundamental desire
for recognition which is right about
yeah go ahead
yeah one question cuz way up could it
could recognition it seemed like
something that you have uh those kind of
dynamics all through your life and
childhood friendship and respect but
I'll cook you a unlike negative and
positive recognition like hey oh stop
like the disrespect if you have respect
yeah I'm disrespect if you have love you
hang yeah so that's kind of a
recognition and a kind of dynamic I
think we'll frog with humans kind of
like something like a recognition well
that's interesting because you know like
so I'll bring up two people one is one
is Hobbes Hobbes talks about you know
love and hate and then contempt yes
contempt is fundamentally different than
neither of those it's you don't take any
account of that that person whatsoever
right yeah good reserve respect at all
yeah and I think for a lot of people
contempt hurts them more than right
hatred does and so that makes I was
going to bring up is because Nietzsche
Nietzsche's you have to think that you
know at least if somebody hates you if
they enough they hit you in the right
way they're still acknowledging human as
respect it's just like pity pity is
account of all contempt to me somebody
pity you they don't respect you and see
you beneath them they think they're
better than you so they pity you yeah
now of course and it still wouldn't be
as good as actually say being logged or
yeah I think yeah having a colleague who
you seek out a lot to work with or
something yeah yeah
like you're right there there we could
distinguish gradations in this June June
no tom has another question do I think
there might be a connection with the
disciplinary regimes of the 20th century
totalitarian regimes gulags Arbeit macht
frei etcetera progress by forcing people
into the role of the slave for their own
good so with the master-slave dialectic
this is actually a great question
because this is where I would say the
master-slave dialectic itself doesn't
really have that component but some of
the other later dialectics could you
know like when we get into the spirit
section and we get freedom and the
terror you know talking about the French
Revolution where yeah it's precisely
this Rousseau Ian we need to make people
be free and we have to do so if need be
by you know terrorizing them
guillotining them yeah now that's not
twentieth-century totalitarian regimes
which are still yet more complex in that
way on but the French Revolution you
might say gets that kind of thing going
this notion of like you're saying
forcing people into the role of the
slave for their own good you know a lot
of the totalitarian regimes didn't arise
solely because capitalism had failed or
you know people just like ruling other
people or things like that it was in
part because they were a way to to
respond to the problem of class conflict
which was tearing you know societies
apart and then there's a there's another
you know sort of inherent dynamic
driving it forward in terms like on the
left of you know his
he's on our side on the right you know
terms of race and identity on the basis
of race and you know I think that that
that's not the man what we could go on
in the master-slave dialectic would be
the development of the slave right so if
you think about say we take somebody
who's actually was formed by those kind
of experiences social needs in right
social needs him was stuck in the gulags
unfortunately after making a joke about
Stalin in a letter and the guy forgot um
you know sent there and somehow was able
to get all of this information out you
know some of it was on notes but a lot
of it was memorized and if you think
about the sort of discipline that was
required for some guy who was just a
tank you know officer and had some some
you know some literacies to be able to
do that um he made it through a crucible
that none of us would want to go through
and none of us would want to put another
person through but it did it did reform
him so you could say that the
master-slave dialectic reworking of the
slave could could fit in there yeah but
I think the Masters in totalitarian
regimes are after something more than
just enjoyment you know I mean some of
them are just about enjoyment you know
you think you think about like somebody
like during for example in the Nazi
regime right yeah he was a mole vivant
and and if you know that meant that he
had to crack a few heads he was okay
with that but somebody like Gribble's
are totally aesthetic not about
enjoyment at all it was it was about you
know power and ideology and domination
so yeah so I think the later discussions
would have more to bear on that stuff
that's coming up in the spirit section
but even then I mean hegel hegel doesn't
really you know I don't think he really
foresees what happened in the 20th
century he can be used to explain some
of it but I don't think he here
sufficiently I mean how could he have
thought that sort of stuff yeah no we
can't yeah we can't hold him any more
than we can hold a card or Aristotle
responsible for you know conceptualizing
a century that didn't exist yeah
are there any other questions we can
take maybe another minute or two
professor Gregory could we can we talk
about this twofold
action how-how-how Anglesey is the
proper way in which we created the
dialect dialectic yeah instead of the
objectives okay I think we talked a bit
about that that I think one thing we
keep in mind is he knows not talking
about this there but there's other
people who've thought about this like in
terms of but we might call
overdetermination every action that you
engage in you have some intention about
what you're trying to do right and that
might be kind of vague usually it refers
to not just the immediate thing that
you're doing like I'm making dinner I'm
making dinner for who my children why
because they have to eat and I want to
keep Child Protective Services from
coming in and blah blah blah why so this
whole matrix but there's there's not
just that you know how the capacity
unpack what the action and the motive is
every kind of your acting in relation to
another person you're you're doing
something and you're also in a way
saying something about the relationship
and how you view them or how you think
they view you and and they're doing
something similar to this is why couples
you know if you want to get the fight
with your romantic partner you can
always find your reason because you can
read anything you can't read something
in the wrong way right or you know a
business partner or whoever so there's
there's always a surplus of meaning that
goes beyond any one single aspect of it
and when we're talking about looking for
recognition from the other person it
gets even more complicated because you
know let's say we think in terms of our
demand for recognition or articulating
it is
or for recognition so that's an action
on our part so there's also an action on
their part in being receptive to that or
are choosing to dismiss it and then
we're also looking to what their actions
are towards us so these things can so
notice when we're analyzing it's getting
very complicated right we do this
implicitly all the time in in each of
the exchanges that we're having with
other people whether we realize it or
not we're the kind of animal that that
does this and learns to do it I mean
some of some people in human society
don't and they're usually very low
functioning and we say well don't don't
trust them with this job or that job
because they can't deal with people
right but most of us do this without
even really thinking about it
we often screw it up we get into fights
with each other you know and bad
feelings about what the other person is
doing sometimes about a good basis but
it's there's a lot of room there for for
an improvement you like today all right
oh god leaks I was going to say that we
can wrap this up so I do have some other
things coming up that I select I would
mention in July I'm going to be tackling
SART on freedom and responsibility in
August we're going to do another you
know free webinar on Plato mob sex and
politics so that means the symposium
right September and then do some Mary
Wollstonecraft and then October which is
the month that it contains stoic weak
and stoic on I'll focus on one of the
Stoics again and epictetus on choice and
some character
you